LAURA INGRAHAM TAKES OVER RIGHT
NOW.
>> Laura: GOOD EVENING FROM
WASHINGTON, THIS IS THE INGRAM
ANGLE, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
IF ANY DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT HAD
PRESIDED OVER THE ROLLING STOCK
MARKET, 2 MILLION NEW JOBS
CREATED IN 2017 AND ROBUST GDP
GROWTH THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
PRESIDED OVER, THE MEDIA WOULD
TEAM.
INTERVIEWING EVERYDAY AMERICANS
THEY BE SAYING?
WE'D BE READING AND HEARING
DAILY ABOUT HOW OTHER COUNTRIES
WERE MARVELING ABOUT HIS BOLD,
AMERICA WASN'T GOING TO BE TAKEN
FOR GRANTED ANY LONGER.
IF NO SUCH LUCK FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PUNDITS AND DNC OPERATIVES
MASQUERADING AS JOURNALISTS.
LIKE A GOOD CAMPAIGN OPERATION,
THIS COMICAL COMMENTARIAT
COORDINATES THE MESSAGING, TAX
REFORM, ENFORCING THE RULE OF
LAW, DEREGULATION, AND THE
TRADE.
PERSONAL ATTACKS.
>> THIS PRESIDENT IS UNSTABLE
AND HE ACTS LIKE A CHILD INSIDE
THE SAME STORIES OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
>> HE HAS THESE ISSUES OF MENTAL
FITNESS AND THESE QUESTIONS OF
INTELLECTUAL CAPACITY.
>> GERMANY, CHINA, BRAZIL, BUT
WHEN WE SAY?
WE WOULD SAY THESE ARE THE
MESSAGES OF SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
WELL.
>> NONE OF THIS STABLE BEHAVIOR.
>> Laura: THE INTERESTING
QUESTION ISN'T WHY THEY ARE
DOING THIS, IT'S WHY AREN'T
REPUBLICANS RESPONDING TO DEFEND
THIS PRESIDENT WITH THE SAME
COORDINATED AND WELL
ORCHESTRATED COMMUNICATION
STRATEGY.
ONE RECENT RAY OF HOPE CAME FROM
CHRISTMAS, THEY CELEBRATED THE
PASSAGE OF TAX REFORM.
THAT IMAGE SENT A POWERFUL
SIGNAL OF UNITY AND SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT THE UNIFIED FRONT AS WE
WE SHOULD LET THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SEAT AND OPTIMISTIC,
DETERMINED, FOCUSED G.O.P. IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
ISSUES LIKE BORDER ENFORCEMENT,
THE WALL, TRADE, REDUCING THE
SIZE OF GOVERNMENT.
WE DO NOT NEED A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT VOICES TALKING AT
CROSS PURPOSES ON THE CORE GOALS
OF THE TRUMP AGENDA THAT WERE SO
POPULAR THAT DROVE HIM TO OFFICE
AS FOR DEFENDING AGAINST THE
HARD WORK OF GOVERNING,
CONSIDERED THE SOURCES AND HOW
SPECTACULARLY WRONG THEY HAVE
BEEN IN THERE SUPPOSE IT AREA OF
EXPERTISE.
>> DONALD TRUMP WILL NOT BE THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE.
>> THAT'S A GUY WHO KNOWS HE'S
GOING TO LOSE PAID >> I DON'T
KNOW THAT HE EVER WANTED TO WIN.
OR SO THAT SHE COULD NOT WIN
SIMPLY BY BEING NOT TRUMP, TURNS
OUT NOT REALLY.
SHE'S NOT TRUMP AND SHE'S GOING
TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WITH A FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT
ELECTORAL MARGIN.
>> THIS IS NOT FUNNY, THIS IS
REALLY BAD.
WE ARE ALL REALLY NERVOUS.
IF PEOPLE OUT THERE FEEL
NERVOUS, WE DO TOO.
WE DON'T THINK THIS IS FUNNY.
ABSOLUTELY HILARIOUS.
THIS IS ALL THEY GOT.
TRUMP'S POLICIES ARE WORKING,
THEY KNOW THEY ARE WORKING, THE
COUNTRY IS WORKING.
THEY CLAIM TRUMP IS OUT OF TOUCH
MAYBE IT'S TIME TO LOOK IN THE
MIRROR.
UNLIKE MANY WHO SAW THE TRUMPED
UP NOT COMING, I DID, I
SUPPORTED THE PLATFORM HE RAN
ON.
I WILL BE CANDID ABOUT THE
PITFALLS AND PROBLEMS ABOUT THIS
ADMINISTRATION FACES.
I WILL POINT OUT THE SUCCESSES
OPPORTUNITIES AS I DID LAST
NIGHT.
>> NOTE WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS
SHOULD HAVE EVER BEEN ENCOURAGED
TO SPEAK WITH A MUCKRAKER LIKE
MICHAEL WOLFE, HOW DID HE HAVE
ACCESS TO THE WHITE HOUSE?
HIS BOOK IS REPLETE WITH ERRORS
AND UNSUBSTANTIATED RUMORS BAD
OR NO SOURCING AND IT CONTAINS
LINES THAT PEOPLE MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE SAID.
RATNER WROTE IN A TWEET BAND AND
MAY SAID ALL THAT STUFF.
LET'S REMEMBER THAT STEVE      M
LET'S REMEMBER THAT STEVE      C
LET'S REMEMBER THAT STEVE      A
WOLFF IS IN    A WRITER OF FICTN
WOLFF IS IN    A WRITER OF FICT.
>> HE CREATES A NARRATIVE THAT
IS NOTIONALLY TRUE, CONCEPTUALLY
>> Laura: AND WOLFF, THE WORK
THAT HE PUT IN HIS BOOK IS WHAT
THE LEFTISTS ARE PINNING THEIR
DREAMS ON?
THIS IS A LEFT WING LALA LAND
THE STUFF.
UNSUBSTANTIATED FACTS.
YOUR POLITICAL INSTINCTS ARE
IN FACT, GALLUP REPORTED THIS
WEEK AT THE END OF DECEMBER THE
PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATING IS
UP TO ITS HIGHEST LEVEL IN SIX
HE'S POISED TO HAVE IT EVEN
BETTER 2018.
THE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO HAVE ALL
THE FIRE AND THE ONLY FURY I SEE